before i at the end of the last video
actually said that we talk about
measures of dispersion or how things are
distributed but before i go that i
realize that i have more to talk about
especially the mean and before i do that
i want to
i want to differentiate between a sample
and a population
a sample
and a population
and i touched on this a little bit in
the last video let's say i wanted to
know i don't know let's say i want to
know the average height of all men in
america
right so let me make the set of all men
in america
so that's all men in america i know
there's 300 million people in the u.s
and half of them may be roughly a man so
this would be 150 million
150 million men
right and it would be nearly impossible
even if i if i was intent on doing it to
actually measure the average height of
every man in america frankly you know
every few seconds one of these men is
being born and one of these men is dying
so you know by the time i'm done
measuring everything someone would have
died and some new new men would have
been born so it would almost be
impossible and if not impossible it
would be very tiresome to to measure
this the the the
average or the mean or the median or the
mode of this entire population right so
the best way i can you know get a sense
of this because i still i'm interested
in what the average of the population is
is maybe i can take the average of a
sample
so what i could do is i could go up to
you know and i try to be pretty random
about it i don't want to like you know i
might hopefully my sample wouldn't be
you know my my college's basketball team
because that would be a skewed sample
but i try to find random people in
random situations where it wouldn't be
you know skewed based on height and i
maybe collect 10 heights and i get well
maybe even you know the more people i
get the more indicative it is but if i
got 10 heights and those 10 heights were
i don't know i'll do it in
you know 5 feet
6 feet
5 and a half feet
5.75 feet
and well let's say i only do six oh
let's see and six and a half feet right
those are the five people that i sample
and we could talk more about what's a
good way to generate a random sample
from a population so it's not skewed one
way or the other but anyway if i wanted
to get a sense of it and if i was kind
of lazy so i only took five measurements
this is the way i would do it and this
would be a sample
this would be a sample of the population
so instead of taking the mean let's say
i wanted that's how i wanted to
calculate the average by taking the
arithmetic mean instead of taking the
arithmetic mean of this entire group of
150 million people i might just be happy
taking the mean of this sample and
that'll be called the sample mean
and i want to introduce you some
notation even though it's it's kind of
so in statistics speak
the mean
this mu
it's greek letter
essentially the greek letter that later
turns into m but mu
is
the population mean and this is just a
convention population
mean
and x with a line over it
that is equal to
a sample mean
sample mean and these are just notations
that people might see and you might have
been confused if sometimes you see
something people talk about means and
you see this mu and sometimes you see
this x with a line over it and that's
and it's nice to know the distinction
here they're talking about the mean of a
sample of the population
and here they're talking about
the mean of the population as a whole
now there the way you calculate them is
essentially the same
this if you want to figure out the
population mean you'd go to all 150
million people at at one moment
and add up all their heights and divide
by 150 million to get the population
mean the sample mean you just add up the
numbers in your sample and divide by the
number of data points you have
and the formulas and this is and i want
to show you i think it's kind of you
know how to calculate averages it's a
it's a fairly straightforward operation
and i want to show you how it's often
written in statistics books so that
you're not intimidated when you see it
the population mean they'll write it as
so just as you know the convention each
member of a
let me do the sample first each member
of a sample say this is the first sample
to call that x sub one
they'll call this one x sub two
they'll call this one x sub three
x sub 4
and then this one x sub 5
right and this is just a way of
referring to each of the samples so on a
sample mean they'll say you know what
you do you take the sum of these numbers
and you know how to do that but the
fancy way of writing it is to say let's
write a capital sigma that means a sum
sum of every x sub n
right take the sum of each of these
numbers right this is x sub 1 x sub 2
where n goes from n is goes from 1
to
i mean you could say to the size of the
population
you know sometimes you know in this case
it would be 5
or sometimes they'd write a big they'd
write an n like that
and you divided by the number of members
there are in that population so divided
by n and then so this is you know when
you see this in a book you're like wow
this is advanced mathematics but
essentially they're saying take the sum
of all the data points just sum up these
numbers and divide by the number of
numbers there are so this would just be
5 plus 6 plus 5.5 plus 5.75 plus 6.5
divided by 5. that's all this is telling
you
for the population mean it's the same
thing they just use a slightly different
notation
they'll say that's equal to the sum
from n is equal to 1
to a big n and i'll explain why they're
at a big n
of each data point in the population not
just the sample
all of that divided by big n
and this is just a way of when they're
at big n they mean 150 million they mean
you know we want you to get every data
point in the entire population so that's
what they mean by and then divide by the
number of the entire population while
with small n they're kind of it's just
the convention the notation that they
say hey
we just want you to get
you know some smaller number not the
entire population but the way you
calculate them is is you know they're
essentially they're essentially
equivalent anyway i wanted to leave you
with that just because
this is something that if you don't get
it clarified early on it's a fairly
simple concept later on it becomes very
confusing when people want to
differentiate between the population and
the sample mean and you see these
formulas written slightly different
sometimes you'll see a mu a mu and
sometimes you'll see an x with a line
over it for the sample mean anyway i'll
see in the next video